while Americans are trying to work out
the difficult problem of what boys and
girls are while American Liberals are
trying to imprison the opposition leader
on a trumped-up seven-year-old charge
our enemies abroad are threatening to
Nuke the world
Dimitri Medvedev the deputy chairman of
the Russian Security Council has just
responded to the international Criminal
Court's arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin by threatening to Nuke any country
that attempts to carry it out he said
quote
let's imagine that it happened the
incumbent head of a nuclear country
arrives in say Germany and is arrested
what does it mean a declaration of war
against Russia in such a case all our
weapons will Target a bundestag the
German Chancellor's office and so on by
the drink or blood and of course this is
the case of course they would threaten
to do this to arrest the leader of a
nuclear former superpower would be to
declare World War III especially after
the United Nations High Commissioner for
human rights has declared that both
Russia and Ukraine have engaged in war
crimes in the ongoing war that threatens
to destabilize the entire world foreign
policy does not usually decide
presidential elections Americans care
more about what's going on at home but
we are living through a steady
escalation of the first major war in
Europe since World War II a war and
escalation that has been entirely
predictable and in fact was predicted
before each and every bungling step made
by the incompetent Biden Administration
the Democrats are all in on the war the
Republicans are split with Trump calling
to wind down the war through a
negotiated peace and the rest of the
Republican field divided on the question
most Republicans just don't want to talk
about it but while the conflict is
complex the options before us are not we
can wind down the war
Salvage most of Ukraine and return the
breadbasket of Europe to the buffer
state it has traditionally been or we
can continue to roll the dice toward a
conflict that threatens to end 80 years
of relative Global Peace most people
think things can't really get that bad
that quickly perhaps they have not paid
attention to the thorough destruction of
our economy rule of law and potentially
even banking system that's taken place
over the last two years perhaps people
didn't pay attention to the only good
advice Barack Obama ever gave us which
is never to underestimate the degree to
which Joe Biden can screw things up I'm
Michael Knowles as the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to this show you know
Barack Obama's wording was a little
harsher than mine I cleaned that up
because this is a family show and as a
family show we will be celebrating all
the important cultural moments such as
women's History Month ESPN celebrated
women's history month this month with a
long tribute to of course William Leah
Thomas we'll get to that in just a bit
first though are we all going to get
nuked is the world over why are we still
in Ukraine what is the purpose of this
war what is the goal here
no one seems to be really sure about
exactly what we're doing if Ukraine
matters if Ukraine doesn't really matter
here's one piece of evidence that we
should not have anything to do with
Ukraine General Millie
the woke General who's really concerned
about white rage and he's he's uh
basically a purple-haired lesbian at
this point and not in in his demeanor he
seems like a Gruff military guy but in
the way he speaks he seems like a
college sophomore transgender Studies
major the way he talks about critical
theory and white rage and all these
questions General milley says Ukraine is
an important National interest which is
the strongest evidence yet that it is
not Millie said it's very clear the
Strategic end state is the global
rules-based international order that was
put in place in 1945 and making sure
that's upheld he said this is an
important National interest
now there are some on the right who are
isolationists who say we shouldn't have
anything to do with the rest of the
world there are others on the right who
say America is the global hegemon And We
Are the World Police and we have not
only a right but a responsibility to
govern the entire world as the global
Empire even if you don't want us to do
it you're gonna you're not gonna like it
when someone else is governing the world
there's Merit to both points I I don't
actually think it's quite so simple as
either of those things but
the the sad fact in practice is that the
people who are running that Global
Empire are completely incompetent
they're complete they just are doing a
terrible job of it
every aspect of this Ukraine war was
predictable
and it's been predicted since the fall
of the Soviet Union since the 1990s and
when we've followed the advice of the
people who are warning about it things
have been okay and when we disregarded
the advice of people like George Kennan
Henry Kissinger or Sam Nunn Daniel
Patrick Moynihan who said NATO should
not get too aggressive NATO should stop
expanding Eastward we shouldn't
necessarily provoke regime change in
Ukraine to to
oust pro-russian leaders we should play
this a little more carefully and a
little less flamboyant than we have been
every time we've ignored that advice the
conflict has escalated
so you might be the biggest Warhawk in
the world and you might say okay we've
got to show American strength at every
point but do you really trust these guys
do you trust Joe Biden you trust mark
milley to do that I don't I don't I
don't think they have an idea of what
they're doing and I think we're just
stumbling into World War III as Russia
is saber-rattling about nuclear weapons
saying oh that could never happen that
could
did you ever think that
he and she would be controversial did
you ever think that women's bathrooms
would be an object of controversy I bet
even five years ago you would have said
that can never happen
and it happens things happen gradually
then suddenly as Andrew Clavin likes to
quote
Ernest Hemingway
and if you it's the only good advice
Barack Obama ever gave if you really
think oh bro oh Joe Biden Can't Screw
things up that much I have got bad news
for you
speaking of irrational Behavior Senator
John Federman who is the Democrat
senator from Pennsylvania he remains
hospitalized John Federman has been in
the hospital now since February 16th
it's almost April and he checked himself
into the hospital because he apparently
is suffering from depression this though
as a result of
a major stroke on the campaign Trail and
then potentially some other Strokes or
stroke-like symptoms so he's been in
there for six weeks and the doctors say
he might remain hospitalized for another
two weeks they keep saying another two
weeks another two weeks and they're
saying he's going to remain hospitalized
for another two weeks to get his
medication exactly right obviously wish
Senator fetterman very well he doesn't
belong in the Senate he should be home
recovering it's horrible with the
Democrats and what his family have done
to him and they should allow the man to
step down and take care of his health in
peace but they're not going to do that
so they're going to try to tweak all of
these powerful psych drugs to get them
to just the right spot where he can sit
in the Senate and give a reliable vote
to Chuck Schumer and Joe Biden which got
me thinking not about John Federman not
about whatever he's going through Walter
Reed hospital right now it got me
thinking of the craziness in our country
people are not rational they're less
rational than usual in our country right
now and everyone's trying to explain why
is it because of critical theory is it
because of Communism is it because of
all the weird sex stuff is it because of
immigrants is it because of I think I've
honed in on an explanation that that
very few people have brought up which
we'll get to in one second first though
when you want some stability in your
portfolio
you got to check out Birch gold right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the FED has
a tendency to print money during times
of economic distress like they did
during the covid-19 lockdowns this has
resulted in the loss of the value of a
dollar and an increase in the value of
precious metals like gold gold will
always have inherent value because it's
a tangible and finite resource
uncontrolled by any single government or
financial institution gold cannot simply
be printed on a whim such as paper
currency as the value of our dollar
continues to decline it becomes
increasingly important to hedge against
inflation by diversifying at least some
of your assets into precious metals the
only company that I trust to help you
diversify and precious metals is Birch
gold Birch gold also makes it easy to
convert your IRA or 401K into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver with
an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company that I
trust to protect my future and so should
you
text nulls kwels to 98 98 98 to claim
your free info kit on gold today and
talk to their precious metals expert
that is Knowles text it to 98 98 98
everybody's looking for the explanation
of why people are so much crazier today
than they have been in the past
has it ever occurred to anyone that may
be the reason people are so crazy today
is because everyone is hopped up on
drugs all the time
not just the the regular drugs not just
the fact that people now wake and bake
and are smoking the devil's lettuce a
lot of the time and people are are
popping all sorts of drugs but I mean
specifically these psychiatric drugs
that huge swaths of the country is on
nearly one in five adult women in the
United States is on anti-depression
drugs
even among teenage girls
it's it's over one in ten are on these
anti-depression drugs a lot of men are
on it too and there are other a lot of
other psych drugs that people are on
there's a fair shot if you're listening
to this show right now that you're on
some of these drugs
and the mass prescription of these drugs
seems to be pretty troubling because
one of the purposes of these drugs is to
short-circuit your ability to engage in
logical thinking that's the point of it
right if you are depressed
and you're for a long time we were told
that people are depressed because of a
chemical imbalance in the brain that
theory that model that representation of
what depression is seems to have been
completely debunked in recent years so
now they're going to come up with some
new image and some new explanation for
it but the one explanation that people
are never allowed to to consider is that
people are depressed because it's
logical to be depressed given the
premises that people begin with if
people begin with the premise that God
doesn't exist there's no hope for
anybody we're all going to pretty soon
take a dirt nap and turn to worm food
all that matters in life is getting
pleasure and so when you're not deriving
pleasure that's really sad along with
other uh other premises that we don't
have a right to a family we don't have a
right to a community that we don't have
a right to normal social relations so we
see that the collapse of all of the
Bedrock political institutions in the
United States all of the things that
give people Joy traditionally
and and no wonder you're going to be
shocked to hear this people are
depressed so then you go to the
psychiatrist and you say hey Doc my
family's falling apart my country's
falling apart I lost my job it was
shipped overseas I I don't my church it
doesn't even exist anymore I know no
one's showing up and everything's
falling apart and I'm kind of depressed
what does the doctor say he says oh good
I got some drugs for you
that almost never treats the actual
problem they say no it's okay I got some
drugs that are going to dull your your
feelings and are going to short-circuit
that logic that has logically LED you to
become depressed
I don't ever think maybe that's why
people are a little bit crazier these
days
you can't I can't help it well I'll
probably get in trouble for even
suggesting that but it seems to me like
if you're going to apply
fifth of the country with very very
powerful psych drugs you shouldn't be
surprised when people start acting a
little quirky speaking of women who
disproportionately take these drugs
politics reportedly is getting very uh
very heated in dating life
so increasingly political difference is
a deal breaker especially for women this
will report out in the hill other people
reporting on the study 86 percent
think that it has grown more difficult
to date someone who supports the
opposing political party in recent years
this according to a 2020 yougov
Economist poll
more than half of men said they would
date someone with different views
whereas only 35 percent of women said
that they would date someone with
opposing views
48 percent of Republicans said they
would date someone with opposing views
because we're rather tolerant 49 of
Independents said the same thing only 40
percent of Democrats said they would
date a Republican
everyone's focusing on this
as it pertains to politics so you're
saying see the Democrats aren't tolerant
the Republicans are tolerant C our
politics is getting so polarized and we
just can't talk to each other and
nobody's in the middle anymore no one
respects differences and sure that might
have something to do with it but I
actually don't think that politics is
the big issue in this story
I think dating is the big issue
specifically I think marriage is the big
issue
the way to explain those numbers is not
that politics has gotten crazy or
politics is always crazy the way to
explain those numbers is to point to how
late people are getting married
as as people put off marriage as people
don't get married at all or they put off
marriage later and later and later what
you're seeing is that people are
becoming more solidified in their views
and as people become more solidified in
their views as people become more
independent as people become formed on
their own it becomes a lot harder to
build a life with someone else
you people are either going to grow
together or they're going to grow apart
so when people were marrying their High
School sweethearts and getting married
at 21 or 22
you're you're barely formed at that
point and so you're going to form
together
but if you're getting married at 32 or
42 or 52 you you are an established
person and so it's unlikely that it at
in your 40s you're going to meet
somebody and have that person completely
change your view of the world
and so these people are saying well now
I'm not willing to date someone with
opposing political views right because
when you're 16 your political views can
change your views on pretty much
everything can change but when you're
older that's much harder so it's an
argument not not for the Democrats even
to get more tolerant or to reach across
the island it's an argument to get
get moving in the dating pool much
younger guys and start settling down
much younger it's not the end of your
life it's really the beginning of your
life and it's the beginning of this new
thing which happens to be the
fundamental political institution
speaking of politics huge political news
very few people are reporting on this
but it tells you a lot about the 2024
presidential primary race
A friend of mine has just signed on to a
pro de Santa Super PAC that would be
Jeff Rowe Jeff Rowe is a very prominent
political consultant and he was the
chief strategist for Ted Cruz he has
been the chief strategist for Ted Cruz
he's been the chief strategist to Glenn
Younkin
and he's worked on a zillion campaigns
he's a total political Legend and now
he's signing on to a Super PAC that it's
called Never back down so it's not the
DeSantis campaign but it's a pack that
exists to serve the DeSantis campaign
and the pack was launched by Ken
cuccinelli Ken cuccinelli is another
legendary Republican figure uh Ken
cuccinelli served as the acting Deputy
Secretary of Homeland Security and
acting director of U.S citizenship and
Immigration Services Under Trump what
does this all mean
this means that the race is
consolidating around Trump and DeSantis
which a lot of people felt was happening
a lot of people could Intuit that that's
what was going on but we're not just
talking about voters or public opinion
polls we're talking about the power
players in the GOP
or consolidating they're they're not
dividing up it's not that some of them
are going to work for Nikki Haley some
are going to work for Tim Scott some are
going to Mike Pence some are going here
some are going there no
is pretty much everybody is picking
either Trump or DeSantis Aaron perine
who was the Press communications
director for Trump's 2020 campaign she
just joined this pack too so she flipped
from Trump to DeSantis she's now working
for It Never Back Down
this is bad news for the non-trump and
DeSantis candidates
the only non-trump and DeSantis
candidate who I think this isn't
necessarily bad news for is Vivek
ramaswamy because the vague is such a
weird candidate he's so out of Life
Field he's never been a governor or
Senator or anything like that he can be
a self-fundder he's made a lot of money
in business so I think
his Lane in the race Remains the weird
quirky kind of outsider
the bad version of that is the Andrew
Yang Lane the good version of that is
the Donald Trump Lane and Vivek is very
sharp and he's he's offering something
different than than the other candidates
are
but what you are seeing here I think is
a lot of anti-trump Republicans and even
some formerly pro-trump Republicans who
just don't think he's the guy this year
they want to avoid what happened in
2016.
in 2016 there were a thousand candidates
in the race and everybody was divided up
among them and Trump pursued a divide
and conquer strategy so Trump could
consistently just get a plurality he
didn't need to get a majority and had
frankly had Marco Rubio and John Kasich
pulled out of the race sooner even if
just Marco Rubio had pulled out of the
race sooner
Ted Cruz very likely would have been the
Republican nominee but because it
remains so divided up
Trump became the nominee so you're
seeing the establishment GOP and just
the people who don't want Trump this
year
they're learning
okay it's the establishment it's the
conservatives who for whatever reason
never like Trump or just don't like him
anymore
they're learning they're saying we're
not going to make the same mistake
again so the question is going to be for
these other candidates are they going to
stay in the race for a long time or is
this going to be a relatively quick
campaign you make a deal with either
Trump or DeSantis you say okay I'll drop
out and endorse you and you got to give
me Secretary of Labor or something like
that seems to be happening very quickly
though even two years out of the race uh
this as Trump's polling is getting a big
boost so we're all waiting on Trump to
get arrested and be thrown into an
orange orange jumpsuit
didn't happen last week
it didn't happen last week didn't happen
the week before that maybe the D.A Alvin
Bragg is getting cold feet here maybe
they're just looking at the polls the
polling right now is is showing that the
potential indictment is helping Trump
according to a Trafalgar group
Convention of States poll
74.3 percent of Americans think of a
trump indictment would help
or not affect his campaign only 25.7
percent think it would hurt so three
quarters of Americans think an
indictment is neutral or good for Trump
only 42.7 percent of Democrats even
think that this would hurt Trump
only 11 percent roughly of the GOP
thinks it would hurt Trump 27 of
Independence
my money is still on Trump to win the
nomination even with all of these other
interests consolidating around DeSantis
right now and DeSantis is very very
talented and very skilled and I'm not
knocking him at all and he's a very good
governor
but right now even with all of that I
think Trump just has such a lead he has
such momentum doesn't mean that
scientists can't become the nominee or
someone else even can't become the
nominee but right now my money would
still be on Trump they've got nothing
Libs have nothing on Trump they've tried
everything that's why they're trying to
indict him on a seven-year-old
trumped-up charge
because they have nothing new the you
know what the you know what they've got
here's what they've got Don Lemon just
showed what the Democrats still have
against Trump
well he raised a whole lot of money by
saying oh I'm going to be you know
insinuating that he was going to be
indicted on Tuesday right raise money
off of that but this is really
disturbing me because he's been doing
this for a while and I think we can't
talk enough about it where he's been
calling uh these prosecutors who happen
to be African-American saying that
they're racist he called Alvin Bragg a
soros-backed animal
yeah he's turning to his old tricks here
of you know
um being a racist or racist adjacent
using that type of language for people
yeah
uh point of question here what is racist
adjacent
Don Lemon reverts to the oldest Democrat
trick in the book you say you're racist
I got nothing we tried Stormy Daniels it
didn't work Russia gate didn't work
Ukraine gay it didn't work we try I
don't know some money thing that didn't
work uh you're racist yeah that'll get
Trump we got him this time the walls are
closing in oh baby yeah it's Mueller
time because we're you're racist
okay whatever
no you're and even Don Lemon knows you
can't make the argument that Trump is
racist if that word means anything
anymore at all you can't make that
argument and so he says you're a racist
adjacent
what's racist to Jason
like you live on a street and David Duke
moved in on the on the perpendicular
Street uh we're racist to Jason we're
not racist but we're racist to Jason
give me a break
doesn't work I mean this is just the
argument against any white person that
you don't like
and white people generally are the least
racist people on earth I mean that in a
very technical way there have been
studies of racial Consciousness white
people have the lowest racial
Consciousness by a country mile every
other race of people has a much higher
racial Consciousness a much higher
in-group preference
white people just are not racist you can
say whatever you want about white people
you can say they have bad taste in music
their food isn't spicy enough but you
can't say they're racist white people
are the least racist people in the world
and and in the United States the white
people are pretty much the only victims
of formal de Yuri systemic racism
Asians get lumped in a little bit too
but white people
and Asians to some degree are the only
group where you can say okay you're
white we're going to discriminate
against you for the purposes of college
admissions for the purposes of hiring
for the purposes of whatever
on the basis of your race so the racism
charge generally Falls flat the racism
charge against Trump definitely Falls
flat and they don't have any other
charge
so what are they going to do what are
they going to say are they even going to
indict him anymore the media the liberal
media are turning on the indictment
itself okay because they've got nothing
we want to deprive them of everything
that they that they want we especially
want to deprive the liberal
establishment of our data which is why
we have to check out expressvpn right
now go to expressvpn.com Knowles
companies are not just selling products
anymore they're selling you
tech companies enrich themselves by
selling your personal data they grab
your web history email metadata and
video searches to create a detailed
profile of you and then sell that off to
the highest bidder when you go online
without a VPN internet service providers
can see every single website you visit
they can legally sell this information
without your consent to ad companies and
Tech Giants who then use it to Target
you with their advertisements that is
why I would recommend using expressvpn
every time you go online expressvpn
anonymizes your online activity by
camouflaging your IP address and
replacing it with a different secure IP
expressvpn also encrypts all of your
data to protect you from hackers and
anyone else that might be trying to spy
on you expressvpn is super easy to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you are
protected so simple even I can do it and
I'm a total Luddite protect your data
with the number one rated VPN provider
today expressvpn.com Knowles to get
three months free in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn dot com
slash Knowles to learn more my favorite
comment
from Fridays from Flat Walsh who says
nulls should come out with a new blank
book reasons to believe in aliens a
comprehensive guide I think we need a
formal debate at the daily wire I think
we need a formal
two podiums
a moderator or Robert's Rules
parliamentary style debate
resolved aliens are are fake
resolved only Libs believe in aliens
speaking of crazy things the libs
believe in
we all know the libs believe in
men being women and it recently was
women's History Month I guess it's still
women's History Month
and to celebrate women's History Month
ESPN decided to run a whole auditory
segment on the most important woman in
sports that would be of course William
Leah Thomas
in 2022 swimmer Leah Thomas became the
first transgender athlete to win an NCAA
division one championship and winning
the 500 freestyle the Texas native
competed for three seasons on the men's
swim team at the University of
Pennsylvania she began her transition
after her sophomore season and after a
gap year due to the pandemic that forced
the ivy league to cancel all sports
Thomas made her debut as a member of the
women's team in December 2021 the
insurance is is not a choice I didn't
have any other choice because foreign
Community competitors and teammates she
said she hopes her persistence serves a
larger purpose
she just trans
ferred Home Advantage
I transitioned to be happy
you know I never said that will Thomas
only transitioned so that he could win
swimming races he was a very low ranked
male swimmer and then he became the
number one ranked female quote unquote
swimmer so maybe that played a role in
it probably did play some role in it but
no I think he transitioned more for the
reason that he says there he said to be
happy now it won't make him happy I
think social science is mostly bunk but
the surveys that we have on this show
that the transition does not actually
make people any happier than they were
beforehand and it it
is not the right thing to do because men
can't become women women can't become
men and your body and soul are united in
a hylomorphic union and everybody on
Earth knew this until five minutes ago
and living according to chopping up your
body and doing all sorts of weird nasty
things is not going to make anybody
happy really in the long run ever it
certainly won't lead to human
flourishing
uh but I I have no doubt that he did it
in part because he's
just confused he's a confused guy he
said I had no choice of course he had a
choice
you didn't need to you could just be
normal you could just act normal and be
normal and you might have some weird
fantasies in your head but you can
either suppress them or sublimate those
fantasies or
indulge them in the privacy of your own
home but not pretend for public purposes
that you're a woman and then go into the
women's locker room and take your
clothing off and start start exposing
yourself to girls who don't want to see
that
you had that choice you just chose not
you chose to deny your own agency and
your own free will in the matter but
forget about will Thomas for a second
I had forgotten about women's history
month because I don't pay attention to
any of the uh liturgical months on the
the liturgical calendar of liberalism I
don't pay attention to Black History
Month I don't pay attention to women's
History Month I don't pay attention to
the now multiple gay months I I have my
own liturgical calendar that I follow
which is the calendar of the church so
we have months too like you know to
marry and um you know at different uh
liturgical Feasts that that do not
celebrate liberalism
but this this proves my point that I
think this is a total vindication
of why we need to ignore all these
liberal months
Black History Month women's History
Month
because
women's history month we can now
conclude with certainty
is not about women
it's not
all the win The Women quote unquote who
have been lauded during women's History
Month
by the White House by ESPN by the
culture they're all men
so it has nothing to do with women it
has everything to do with liberalism and
leftism Black History Month
is only tangentially related to black
people
true ESPN doesn't run fawning profiles
of Rachel dollazal
they haven't they haven't yet embraced
trans-racialism but likewise you're not
going to see any fawning profiles of
Clarence Thomas you're not going to see
any fawning profiles of Thomas Soul
you're not going to see any falling
profiles of Booker T Washington for that
matter you're not going to see any
following profiles of Candace Owens I
don't think no you're only going to see
a certain kind of black person
and and very often a manufactured
leftist caricature of a certain type of
black person this is not about black
people it's about liberalism
and leftism
so we should ignore all of that
ignore all of those
things how about for for the gay months
you're never going to see profiles of
of men who let's say they have some
desire and they just don't act on it
will Thomas says I had no choice but to
chop my body parts off and pretend to be
a woman yet you could have not done that
you could have just been normal you
could have by that I mean you could have
acted in accord with the norms and
standards set by Society
through their use of right reason and
their deference to the wisdom of the
Ages which is a far better guide to
human flourishing than what some quack
doctors in the 60s decided it was was
best for for confused men which is to
mutilate themselves and live according
to a fantasy
could it just been normal
of course of course you have this but
you never see
you you never see
LGBT History Month celebrating
d-transitioners Helena kirschner it's
not going to be is not going to be
Walt higher is not going to be
celebrated
and any of the multiple LGBT history
months so it's kind of funny it's it's
dark but it's kind of funny that will
Thomas is the woman of the month the
woman of the year for women's History
Month on ESPN
sometimes it's a lot less funny there's
a video that went viral I had our
editors blur basically the whole thing
but you can get a little sense of it
anyway
a 13 year old drag queen a little boy
who was dressed up in sexual clothing to
look like a girl like a very sexualized
girl was just videotaped and went viral
dancing around at a club while a bunch
of pervert adults cheered him on
he didn't sort of vaguely make out he's
wearing these leather stiletto heels and
a leather kind of dress skirt thing and
is dancing around in a very sexualized
posture and then these total freak
perverts on the side are cheering him up
they're what are they cheering on
they're cheering on a sexual performance
of a 13 year old boy dressed in a tight
leather outfit
this isn't
well you know the slippery slope might
be slipping down this isn't some
conspiracy theory
idea there are there are Elite heados in
our culture and they have a lot of power
and you know you've got to talk to the
Illuminati and the rosicrucians and I
don't know some tinfoil hat stuff
it's on video
you're watching it
even the idea of an elite pedo ring
that's so Elite that they have I don't
know let's say their own private island
in the Caribbean and some of the most
notable wealthy powerful people on Earth
go to this island to do weird stuff with
very young underage people
that's not a crazy conspiracy theory we
have the court documents we have
pictures in some cases
that's
real that's happening
it reminds me of a line from Oren
McIntyre who's been on this show before
great political commentator
and he says guys it's not that
complicated they just wanted little kids
it's a little more complicated than that
I do think there is an ideological
aspect of this whole weird sexual
movement that we're seeing I do think
that ultimately it it stems from the
political project of liberation of
liberalism that liberalism begins with
the idea of liberating yourself from
Dusty old conventions and liberating
yourself from superstition
non-scientific beliefs which we're told
today are allegedly superstitious uh
liberating yourself from the old
political order the ancient regime now
we're going to live in a revolutionary
political order liberating yourself from
the moral order liberating yourself from
the family the fundamental political
institution ultimately
liberating yourself from yourself that's
what the transgender transition is about
the transgender transition is a ritual
suicide it's not a literal suicide but
it's a ritual figurative suicide
through which
a person kills himself he then refers to
the person that he has been literally as
a dead name
says that person is dead talks about
that person in the third person and in
the past tense and then out of that dead
person a new identity
is allegedly born through this ritual of
suicide because that is the ultimate
liberation of the self from the self the
the only
absurd illogical conclusion of that but
but it is the inexorable conclusion from
the the premises of liberalism is is
suicide that's that's the way out and
it's all terribly wrong and it's led to
a cultural suicide and a National
Suicide and that's where the logic leads
you to so I do think that's all there
but also all of that is prefaced to say
some of these people just want to ditto
kids
that's it those the guys there cheering
lusting after a 13 year old boy in in a
leather outfit and stilettos jiggling
around
they're just perverts
and they their desires need to be
suppressed by Society
I know that we live in the age of Love
Is Love and no no desire is ever to be
considered disordered or wrong or to be
repressed they need to be suppressed
yeah
they need to be laws against this there
need to be Norms against this we need to
round up the men who go to shows like
this and we need to lock them away in
institutions or prisons and we need to
tell other people that if they have any
desires that are in in any way even
close to resembling this sort of thing
they need to Tamp that down
and stop stop doing it in public and
stop doing it in private just cut it out
sometimes things can be really simple
like that there's a story that I had to
get to before we go before we get to the
member block today is music Monday so
for the crime.com Inner Circle audience
at the Nostradamus member of segmentum
we will be getting to a very important
song
that Mr Davies has for me
but
before that
you know that I'm really tough on on
immigration
uh there are very few people
who are tough around immigration than I
am I think obviously we've got to stop
illegal immigration build a border wall
enforce the Border policies I think we
should drastically reduce legal
immigration as well most Americans
according to at least some surveys want
to drastically reduce legal immigration
we just are taking too many people in 2
million illegals per year are Crossing
into the U.S and then a million legal
immigrants as well
we've been keeping this up for 60 years
now it's the largest movement of people
ever in recorded history it's just too
much if you're not assimilating people
can't do it so I'm really tough on that
however
I'd like to make an exception
because of this headline
two Cuban migrants fly into Florida on a
motorized hang glider
two migrants used a motorized hang
glider to fly 90 miles from the
Communist island of Cuba to Key West and
they landed safely at Key West
International Airport at about 10 30 A.M
I think those guys should stay
I I want to hire those guys I don't even
know I don't know what they would do
around here they can they can start
Jeremy's Jeremy's airplanes
Jeremy's hang gliders I love the Cuban
people one because they make great
cigars too because they're relatively
quite conservative and when they come to
America they disproportionately vote for
Republicans I like that that inclines me
to letting more of the Cubans stay it's
it's why by the way Barack Obama as he
opened up the border to everybody and
and gave uh unconstitutional executive
amnesty to illegal aliens specifically
from Latin America the one group that he
restricted immigration for by repealing
the wetfoot dry foot policy
it was Cubans and why because the Cubans
tend to vote Republican
just shows you nakedly that the
Democrats immigration policy is just
about getting more votes has nothing to
do with care for poor oppressed people
Barack Obama he was sucking up to
communist Cuba he doesn't like that the
Cubans vote for Republicans he says okay
you're the ones you can't do it
so I'm inclined to like these Cuban
people and I think I just think
if you have the guts
and the ingenuity
to get a single person light hang glider
that's supposed to go
you know jumping from puddle to puddle
and then you you take that and you fly
90 miles across shark infested waters to
Florida and then land safely at the
airport
I want you I'm in we can have we can
have an immigration moratorium other
than two people I want these two
these two Cubans bienvenitos Amigos
welcome to Los Estados unidos
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking Michael
huh how did you get your hair so shiny
and voluminous and spectacular
the quaff is just out of control how do
you do it Michael well the answer
Jeremy's
Jeremy's razors shampoo and conditioner
that's right Jeremy's razors it's more
than just a razor company fighting to
protect your values it's also a Men's
Grooming brand that doesn't hate men and
This Magnificent quaff that you see here
is fortified every morning thanks to
Jeremy's tea tree and Argan Oil infused
shampoo and conditioner that's not all
oh no Jeremy's also has an exfoliating
charcoal body wash made with
hydrating aloe vera eucalyptus and just
the right amount of pomegranate not you
don't want too much pomegranate in your
charcoal body wash no way the men's care
products that you see here are made with
natural ingredients we are 100 sulfate
free paraben free woke free made right
here in the US of a head on over to
jeremy'srazors.com to kick woke
companies out of your bathroom today
also a new episode of yes or no is
available with my friend Matt fradd
host of pints of Aquinas it's out on
YouTube if you've ever wondered what
it's like to trade places with me to
become the host and wield the undeniable
power of
a drink and good opinions and
those game cards on the most titillating
topics of our time you're in luck you
can do that when you pre-order yes or no
the game from dailywire.com shop it's a
beautiful mysterious game full of
controversy and conspiracy sold out
instantly last year don't wait to secure
your copy supplies will not last prove
how well you know your friends and
family and discover how well they know
you when you bring home yes or no the
game
available only at dailywire.com slash
shop
now
before we go
before we go here uh
we all we're talking about the
transgender issue all the time in
women's history month now I guess uh I
guess women's History Month celebrates
men who think that they're women there
is a point that an Olympic athlete just
made her name is Sharon Davies former
British Olympic swimmer
I celebrated this decision by the world
Athletics to ban the trans-identifying
athletes from women's events publicly
thanking the organization's president
a Sebastian Co and here's what she said
she said women are not a testosterone
level
this was always a bogus argument and
should never have been considered a
waste of time and money male biology
a male biology Advantage is uh real it
cannot be fully mitigated against
females of all ages and all sports are
deserving a fair safe sport as much as
males get no one's banned from sport
just just a category they don't qualify
for
I have heard a lot of conservatives say
look what are we going to do with the
transgender thing let's just we'll just
test people's testosterone if you've got
too much testosterone then you've got to
compete with the men and then if you
don't have enough testosterone you
compete with the women
no
guys yes some people have more
testosterone than others not every man
is just a brimming
with virility and testosterone like some
of us here okay some people are at a
disadvantage in that regard
but they can still be men
are not just testosterone women are not
just estrogen to accept the testosterone
levels standard for sports is to accept
transgenderism
is to accept the idea that men and women
are
either entirely reducible to their
bodies or not at all reducible to their
bodies
which is which is what they say
the transgenderists hold both views
they'll say hey if I chop my
Family Jewels off and I get prosthetic
breasts and I put on a wig and I put on
a dress I am really a woman if I have
the appearances of a woman then I really
am a woman
or they'll say no it doesn't matter I
could have a big beard I could be big
Husky Hank walking into the women's
locker room but if I think that I'm a
woman then I'm a woman
but both of those views are not correct
because human beings are not just body
and we're not just not body
we're Body and Soul together
the body is our material self the soul
is the substantial form of our body
sex derives from the body from our
natural
body and it applies to the whole person
as an Inseparable accident that persists
as long as the individual exists we just
are
we just are a man
or we are a woman
and you if Sports in many ways even male
Sports you're you're judging how manly a
man is and the manly or men are going to
beat the less manly men in a lot of
sports
well the less manly men are still men
and a lot of the point of the sport is
to figure out who's the best competitor
women are not just estrogen they're not
a testosterone level
women are a real category
a real natural category and no amount of
tinkering and scientific Witchcraft and
ideological Jumping Jacks and
somersaults none of that is going to
change what a man is and what a woman is
you saw another example of this
absurdity over the weekend some dude won
a women's cycling event I believe in New
York
photo was going around the internet
you see that down there on the number
three
spot you see some woman holding her
trophy in the air whatever I guess a
bottle of champagne then on the number
two spot you see another woman smiling
she's got her bottle of champagne and
then on the number one spot is a big
hulking dude both arms in the air with a
bottle of champagne
and if I were the husband of the number
two woman I would be really really angry
at the dude in the number one spot
because you're looking at this picture
and you you look and you think oh that
number two woman yeah she did a good job
but she just wasn't yeah she wasn't the
best but she actually was the best woman
in the race and she deserves to be in
the number one spot
and I don't know if there was a prize
associated with this
very often the arguments against men
competing in women's sports is is that
well the men could take the women's
scholarships you know there's a real
Financial harm that's done here to women
when the men get to compete or the the
men could get into college
there's a real uh
you know harm educational harm to the
women here because the guy could take
the spot at the college
but even just the glory of the thing
even why do people engage in Recreation
and Leisure in sports and part of it is
just for the glory for excellence to
demonstrate excellence and and so that
that other people can Marvel at that
excellence and that woman was robbed of
her rightful place by a very confused
man a very disturbed man that we are all
indulging and that's just it's just
wrong
even as a matter of
celebration and Sport
and Glory
okay it is it is a non-sequitur that if
a guy just chops off a body part or
takes some estrogen or something that he
becomes a woman speaking of
non-sequiturs
we love
on the right we love when a liberal
seems a little bit more conservative and
so everybody is fawning over Bill Maher
and I kind of like Bill Maher did a bid
on his show the other day about me after
my seat back speech it was pretty funny
I get generally get a kick out of Bill
Maher but Bill Maher
Bill Moore has this problem where he
he'll make a good point
and then totally undercut his point he
just did that on the religion of climate
change
all right so um we had yet another one
of those reports this week from the U.N
Intergalactic panel run climate or
that's not the real name of it but it's
something like that I feel like I talk
about Groundhog Day I feel like I've
written written I've read this report
every year and it's always the same the
world is coming to an end which I think
it is by the way I I think disaster is
coming but they always seem to predict
very specifically when and some of those
dates have already passed I think they
should first of all stop doing that you
know because it really bleeds their
credibility it's kind of like what the
Western Medical establishment found out
about covid don't lie about it
people you will lose their credibility
yeah right they don't have credibility
anymore the Western Medical
establishment burned their credibility
during covid the sky is going to fall
climate people have burned their
credibility for 50 years now because all
their doomsday predictions keep being
proven false
and yet
Bill Maher says and I think the world is
ending yeah I think they're right
you know I think they're right
ultimately but they're just they're
tarnishing a lot of their credibility so
it's just they need to stop they need to
be more cautious
well I thought Bill Maher was The
Logical guy I mean I never thought Bill
Murray was The Logical guy but he
presents himself as I'm the rational guy
I'm The Logical guy
I'm an atheist I just follow the science
what's he say he says well
all the evidence says the world isn't
ending all the people claiming the world
is ending have been proving been proven
wrong time and time again that all the
people who claim the world is ending
have been proven wrong even on other
predictions they've made not related to
their claims about the world ending
but I still believe the world is ending
this
is cognitive dissonance
of the highest caliber
but it's much easier
for these liberals
to convince themselves of something that
they had previously just they just
immediately admitted was not true they
can convince themselves to continue to
believe in it
more easily than they can convince
themselves to change their behavior and
decease to be liberals
they just can't it's so devastating I
remember as I became more and more
conservative than I previously had been
I remember thinking man it must be
really it is really hard to give up
liberalism because liberalism defines
our whole political order or at least
has for a long time now and to give that
up and to say wow it's wrong the
predictions they make are wrong the
things they say about human nature are
wrong they now say men or women women
are men it was wrong the things they say
about the human person the things they
say about Society it's all it's just
wrong they're just wrong
and they don't have credibility so when
people keep getting things wrong and
they don't have credibility you know
what you got to do you got to stop
listening to them and start listening to
people who make more sense
that's what we do over on the
Nostradamus membrane segmentum okay we
talk to people who make sense they crème
de La Creme if you're part of the Hoy
paloi here on YouTube get on over to
daily wire go to dailywire.com use code
Knolls at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
oh